bioinformatics for infectious diseases
is an online training program designed
for biologists clinicians and students
that are interested in biology and
immunology and would like to learn about
the use of bioinformatics and big data
for infectious disease research
Diagnostics as well as drug and vaccine
development as we hear more and more
about infectious diseases in the news
for the first time we can learn about
recent outbreaks and even current Rhona
virus epidemic by analyzing data that is
made available for the research
community with increasing speed and in
increasing volumes just for this ongoing
coronavirus outbreak detailed maps of
reported cases genomic information from
viral strains protein structures and
other data is being updated on a daily
basis opening the door for anyone to
access and use this information that's
why we designed this program to
introduce the data resources and tools
that you can use to apply bioinformatics
to publicly available data on infectious
diseases in this program we will
understand viral diversity and its role
in epidemic infectious diseases that
keep reemerging including zone otic
transmission transmission between humans
and the process of viral and bacterial
disease development learn about bio
informatics analysis approaches to study
viral genomes and understand
relationships between viral strains and
haplotypes finding differences in
sequence data and seeing the implication
for drug and vaccine design gain
hands-on experience by analyzing curated
datasets from public domain collections
guided by experts with bioinformatics
expertise and knowledge about biology
we'll see how bioinformatics can help us
understand zone otic transmission viral
replication and adaptation to various
tissues in our body helping overcome our
immune response together we will
understand how the data analysis tools
can help detect viral genomes in
next-generation sequencing data identify
specific viral strains and haplotypes
from NGS files like fast queue and fast
a.apply comparative analysis to gain
insight into vaccine design and look
into the principles of antiviral drug
design as well as the development of
resist
and substandard drugs including
superbugs that do not respond to
antibiotics the program will provide
several examples of disease projects
with curated datasets and guided
analysis sessions to see how
bioinformatics is used for infectious
disease research in every example we
will use the epidemic outbreak data and
study it to understand what we can learn
and how we can analyze the factors
contributing to the rate of infection
the disease outcomes and other symptoms
that are being recorded linking them to
viral data we will also discuss major
publications that came out during or
after these epidemics and see how
volumes of available data and innovative
approaches to data analysis led to major
discoveries that resulted in better
understanding of disease development of
vaccines antiviral drugs and a deeper
understanding of disease progression
that is changing how we apply diagnostic
and intervention strategies in current
outbreaks well we'll see how one can
find download and use the data that is
freely available on NCBI but this data
requires effective use of bioinformatics
analysis methods to process analyze and
interpret biologically meaningful
patterns so we will learn about these
analysis approaches and study viral
genomes and practice on curated data
sets that have been prepared annotated
and tested by our team we will learn to
use the intuitive t bio info platform
that anyone can use without any coding
background or expertise where such
analysis can be performed easily for
large numbers of viral genomes or even
next-generation sequencing data that
comes directly from patients for example
we will learn about phylogenetic
relationships between different viral
strains by performing a similar analysis
on our own and understanding how we can
visualize and study this kind of data in
a meaningful impractical way by
practicing analysis on the prepared
datasets
you will understand the meaning of each
step and will be able to design an
analysis
pipeline of your own obtaining
biologically interpretable results and
then visualizing those to share with
others we will also review examples and
several tools developed to help navigate
big datasets and connect the various
aspects of sequence structure and
metadata into a single experience this
will help us map mutations on 3d
structures of viral proteins which can
be studied separately or in complexes as
they are found during viral replication
inside the cell we will learn how we can
use the genomic data analysis to see the
changes between viral strains and
different significance levels of
detected changes due to their 3d
position on protein structures so we
will find that multiple sequence
alignment can be a powerful tool to
understand viral adaptation between
animals and humans and study the
relationship between viral and host
proteins like the trimeric SARS
coronavirus surface spike glycoprotein
that binds to the cellular receptor
angiotensin-converting enzyme to and
mediates fusion of the viral and
cellular membranes to a pre and post
fusion conformation transition this type
of structural data is also important for
antiviral drug design like this n sp1
hosts translation inhibitor which
facilitate efficient viral gene
expression in infected cells and evasion
from host immune response we will also
discuss the relationship between concert
regions and viral proteins the structure
of small molecule binding sites and the
efficacy of antiviral drug design for
diverse viral populations or haplotypes
that are typically present in a given
outbreak we welcome you to join the
program
we invite students biologists and
clinicians that see the value and
opportunity of Big Data to study and
understand infectious diseases and their
agents viruses and bacteria the program
will start May 4th 2020 we welcome you
to register early to benefit from early
bird discounts and ensure availability